Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmetische angelegenheiten mein name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur neunundsiebzigsten,
ausgabe von Raumzeit des neunundsiebzigsten gespräch,
und ja ich sag in letzter zeit immer so schön raumfahrt und andere kosmetische angelegenheiten,
heute gehts definitiv um andere kosmetische angelegenheit und vielleicht in gewisser hinsicht sogar um die kosmetische angelegenheit,
schlechthin heute wollen wir nämlich sprechen über die chemie die cosmo chemie oder auch cosmos chemie kann man sicherlich auf die eine oder andere art und weise bezeichnet,
letztlich die frage nach allem was jenseits der physik das universum so zusammengetragen hat,
wie wir es heute vorfinden und,
was auf die grundlage ist für unser leben und um doch aber mal ganz ausführlich zu sprechen,
in die schweiz gefahren konkret nach bern an die universität bern an das physikalische institut,
das hat nämlich dann noch ein center auf space and the city und,
bis vor kurzem vor zwei jahren war kathrin alt weg die direktorin dieses centers und von daher begrüße ich sie auch herzlich hallo frau.
War richtig zusammengetragen vor zwei jahren haben sich dann sein lassen aber sie haben's lange betrieben oder.
Sehr lange direktorin weil das wurde gegründet im zweitausendelf weil wir eben sehr erfolgreich waren im weltraum forschung hat die uni da mehr geld locker gemacht,
da hat man dieses zenter gegründet was eigentlich für intensiv arbeiten steht,
also wir haben mit training bio chemiker gelogen aber dann auch theologen und philosophen zusammengearbeitet.
Also ging es gar nicht mal nur um chemische fragen sondern eigentlich um alles.
Eigentlich das leben und den ursprung des lebens also woher kommen wir wohin gehen wir und sind wir alleine.
Das klingt nach einem ganz guten leid motiv für unsere heutige sendung,
bevor wir da einsteigen würde mich aber natürlich erstmal interessieren wie sind sie denn zu diesem thema oder beziehungsweise überhaupt zu allem was mit chemie und raumfahrt zu tun hat gekommen,
war das schon immer so in ihrer dna oder was er zufall gibt ja beide geschichten.
Es war wahrscheinlich schon eher zufall also ich habe gerne naturwissenschaften ich bin auch aus einer,
wissenschaftlichen familie ich habe aber lange überlegt ob ich euch logisch studieren wollen,
physik entschieden und hab festgestellt musik gemacht als schwerpunkt den würde man heute technologie.
Haben in basel die sortiert zusammen mit meinem mann,
haben uns kennengelernt sind dann zusammen ins ausland nach new york für zwei jahre.
Immer noch auf diesem gebiet und dann hoffen wir,
grafisch am selben ort abgesucht und das war ein paar zufall in bern,
ein job an der universität in forschung in der telekommunikation und die firma in der telekommunikation für jeweils unvorstellbare eine frau anzustellen zu dir.
Aber haben sie dann doch gemacht oder.
Nein ich habe dann meine mama angestellt und damit muss ich an die uni.
Okay das ist jetzt wirklich zufall okay.
Und so bin ich gelandet und ich sage immer die weltraum forschung hat mich gesucht nicht.
Den eindruck macht das und womit hat sich dann die weltraum forschung zu dem zeitpunkt beschäftigen wird von welchem jahr reden wir jetzt von dann ging es los.
Von neunzehnhundert,
zweiundachtzig habe ich hier begonnen da habe ich zuerst begonnen mit magneten sphäre,
unsere atmosphäre aber dann baut schon kam das projekt,
der flug zum comedian harley,
und das war eine sehr schnelle mission man hat so im einundachtzig,
begonnen und das ist extrem kurz für eine weltoffene mission,
und dann hatten sie dann personalmangel und sorgen sie umgepolt auf,
vor allem die software gemacht.
Lotto und rosita in kombination weil die beiden projekte hängen ja auch eng zusammen auch in ihrer vita hatte ich ja schon mal bei raum zeit ausgabe nummer zwanzig mit gerhard schwimmen besprochen der
damals durch der prinzipiell investigative warum ich das richtig erinnere für die ganze wissenschaft von.
Projekt ist.
Projekt den sehr wahrscheinlich dann auch,
gut kennen ja das war ja breaking auf die esa damals ganz wichtiges ein erfolgreiches projekt der flug eben zu diesem,
kometen eigentlich auch für den mythische,
mythos besten kometen der zu dem zeitpunkt zumindest zu greifen war mag jetzt abgelöst worden sein im rahmen,
aber das ging ja dann wirklich ziemlich ziemlich fix also sechsundachtzig war dann der vorbei flug was was war denn da ihre aufgabe.
Verantwortlich für die software und dann für die datenanalyse.
Also für die software von von was also.
Von vom instrument dass man hier in berlin kann nicht sagen gebaut hat sondern koordiniert,
zu der zeit war die schweiz schlecht finanziert für instrumente es waren.
Massen spektrum meter hatte zwei sensoren das hieß und das hörst das hieß kaum effektiv von lindau deutschland vom herrn rosenbaum und das hörst kampf von.
Was heißt es und hörst.
Das es passt eben oder das heißt vom herrn rosenbaum und das hört von den gebaut,
aber es sind noch die abkürzung dass eine heisst intensive sensoren und das andere.
Und wir in bern stellt einen prinzipiell investigative professor und wir müssen das ganze trainieren und die instrumente wollten bei uns gerecht getestet.
Und wir haben sie dann auch abgeliefert in kultur,
ich war verantwortlich für alle software dieselben braucht um diese instrumente zu checken auftreten die software die damit geflogen ist sondern man,
und damit war ich natürlich in sämtlichen test sinnvoll wird beim vorbei flug involviert bekommen wir die daten sofort,
und nachher instrumente sehr genau komm.
Da waren ein paar jahre mit.
Ja also das war ja schnell fast siebzig kilometer pro sekunde geschwindigkeit vielleicht zwei stunden daten und wir haben da nicht zehn jahre ausgewählt.
Das ist ein ganz gutes verhältnis ähm vielleicht in dem zusammenhang was muss man sich jetzt unter einem massen spektrum pop und diese beiden instrumente.
Ein massen spektrum meter.
Drum meter.
Wir haben wirklich teilchen das kometen geladenen millionen massen spektakel,
gemessen und zwar ihre masse bestimmt.
Also die sind ins instrument reingeflogen und wir haben sie separiert nach ihrem masse mit magnet und elektrischen feld das kann man gerade nicht helfen.
Also es war dann quasi so teilchen nachdem man an den kommenden vorbeigeflogen wäre.
Während wir haben die koma gemessen die atmosphäre das.
Das instrument separiert die dann nach wesentlicher nach gewicht.
Und dann hat man am schluss ein massen spektrum also man hat zwölf das wäre ein stoff bei wasser oder ein zwei.
Und und am vierundvierzig euro zwei und das war's schon ungefähr bei ehemals aus unserem maßen bereich hat dann aufgehört.
Und wir hatten auch nicht eine sehr gute auflösung,
zum beispiel ein zweites beide konnten wir nicht separieren.
Aber wir haben gesehen dass der komet extrem viele moleküle teilt und eben auch schwerer.
Und das war eine überraschung.
Das war eine große überraschung ich meine wir sind mit schotter losgeflogen um zu zeigen dass das wasser hat im kommen.
Und dass es einen festen kern hat derzeit immer noch nicht sicher ob das nur so eine am himmel oder ob es wirklich einen festen,
das war das ziel von otto und wir haben sehr viel mehr erreichen.
Dass es ja auf jeden fall belegt worden,
bevor wir vielleicht mal so auf diese fragestellung kommen weil es ja immer so dieses okay was schaut man sich überhaupt an was man eigentlich wissen,
müssen wir ja vielleicht mal ein bisschen zurückgehen und sich gedanken machen welche rolle eigentlich die chemie so spielt ich bin es kann auch was er sagt sie haben nur physik studiert,
oder ist an dem noch ein chemisches studium gefolgt später.
Nein ich habe im leben einfach.
Ah im leben fach alles klar aber es ist so ein bisschen dann das haupt fach geworden über die zeit.
Ja vor allem in den letzten jahren schon.
Ja der weltraum unendliche weiten wie man die chemie spielt ja ihre rolle mein mann tendiert glaube ich immer so ein bisschen dazu über das weltall einfach immer so auf der basis von physikalischen,
phänomen und gesetzen nachzudenken gravitation hält alles zusammen und dann fliegt es halt auch mal irgendwie auseinander und all diese ganzen physikalischen ereignisse,
stehen so ein bisschen im vordergrund aber so diese die chemie sozusagen wird eigentlich nicht so oft diskutiert ist das jetzt nur so meine falsche sicht der dinge ist eigentlich ganz anders oder ist es auch ihre wahrnehmung.
Ich glaube die auftrag ist ein relativ neues gebiet das ist der seit wenigen jahren dass man das beobachten kann von werte aus,
und dass man sich gedanken darüber gemacht das material kommt aus dem unser universum unser sonnensystem unserer erde,
noch reden bei,
eine große diskussion und man hat gesehen dass wirklich.
Vorhanden sind und seit dem man jetzt richtig gerade machen kann sieht man das auch,
vor allem mit all meinen ziele sehen sie alle kühle überall im weltall und komplexer moleküle.
Einmal das große teleskop oben fünftausend meter in der kama wüste der beste blick die man glaube ich so aus universum haben kann auf der erde zumindest wo ja ich glaube sechsundsechzig,
gruppe zusammengeschnürt sind das ist natürlich eine enorme auflöst.
Und das ist eben nicht optisch dass es dann in welchem bereich,
und da sieht man wirklich moleküle.
Man sieht den stern des sommers im stern drin stecken oder was immer mal anschauen.
Jetzt sind ja moleküle im prinzip so die der fortgeschrittene zustand da hat sich ja dann schon mal überhaupt irgendwas zusammengebaut fallt,
man tendiert ja erstmal dazu so die die welt einfach erstmal eine offene summe von atom zu sehen,
angefangen hat ja mit dem,
also das ist zumindest der aktuelle aktuelle sicht der dinge sagen wir es mal so mit dem ur knallen was auch immer davor gewesen sein mag und im wesentlichen bestand auf das weltall zunächst einmal nur aus wasser.
Was wann,
wann fing denn sozusagen chemie überhaupt erst an also,
gab's ja dann sozusagen erstmal noch noch gar nicht oder weil wenn man da jetzt mal so salopp draufschaut war ja noch nicht ausgemacht dass das überhaupt so alles zueinander passt und sich so wild kombinieren kann.
Sie haben recht oder im stand im wesentlichen wasserstoff ein bisschen helium bis juli zum sieben aber sonst nichts wäre,
und dann haben sie sich diesen sterne gebildet und sterne sind eben fabriken für schwere atome.
Und jetzt kommt so ein bisschen darauf an wie groß der stern ist unsere sonne die klein,
die macht auch funktion weil in einem stern der besteht aus gas also wasserstoff im wesentlichen,
und weil sterne so groß sind haben sie gravitation auf sich selber das heißt sie ziehen das gas zusammen bis eben die atomkraft so nahe kommen dass sie fusionieren können dem sagt man nukleare.
Also weil die hitze einfach dadurch so enorm ansteigt unter dem eigenen gewicht wird alles zusammengepresst und bei den temperaturen kann dann die fusion überhaupt erst statt.
Genau ganz genau und in kleineren sternen wir unsere sonne da,
können sie kohlenstoff machen also drei sie machen zuerst mal,
drei helium zusammen gibt an einen kohlenstoff dann ein helium dazu gibt sauerstoff und so können sie im prinzip das periode ein system aufbauen,
mit einem und das hört dann auch beim eisen,
weil eisen ist das beste gebundene hat den best gebundenen atomkrieg.
Was macht das so so gut.
Dann ist es energetisch in einem absoluten minimum und da kommen sie dann fast nicht mehr um weiter zu gehen wenn sie mal gelandet sind bleiben sie dort.
Das heißt das eisen ist so sich selbst genug sozusagen das.
Stabiles elemente hin genau.
Strebt nirgendwo hin und was wäre dann der nächste schritt.
Und es ist es gibt ja schweren elemente und die entstehen bei super nova explosionen.
Egal wie groß ein stern ist nur durch dieses unter der eigenen last zusammen pressen des materials kann nicht mehr als eisen entstehen und das kann man ausrechnen.
Das kann man als energetischen gründen ausrichten.
Ok was ist denn dann sozusagen das nächste element jetzt hab ich 's perioden system gerade nicht so im aber alles was sozusagen darauf danach kommt braucht einfach mehr power und diese power gibt's nur durch explosion.
Genau genau ein super noch einmal viel heißer,
noch einmal viel höher und dann könnt ihr noch schwere elemente entstehen.
Aber auch nur begrenzt nun die überreste der eine super das sind neue drohnen sterben.
Kobalt ist der nächste.
Dann gibt es neue drohnen sterne aus der super nummer und schönen haben ja nur noch neue tonnen und damit haben sie keine,
auseinander treibenden kräfte mehr zwischen den geladenen teilchen und da kommt dann das material auch sehr nahe zusammen die neue.
Sie sind also klein wegen dem aber extrem massen reich das kann jetzt auf keinsten volumen kann sehr viel masse haben,
und jetzt neu dronen sterne die entstehen meistens im doppel der zweifel eins,
die sind sehr häufig zu zweit es gibt zwei sterne und weil sie so maßen reich sind doch klein ziehen sie sich gegenseitig und irgendwann kommt zu kollision,
und das sind dann kilo nova,
in einer kilo sind die bedingungen noch einmal viel extreme und dann können sie die wirklich schwierig momente machen wie zum beispiel.
Kein gold ohne neu dronen stark.
Genau also kennt sie nicht zur bank kaufen sie sich zwei null.
Ich hab schon ein schönes gespräch mit content tina aus mainz über neutralen sterne gerade
eine woche bevor dann die große nachricht kam das erstmalig über die gravitationswellen genauso eine,
hannover beobachtet werden konnte beziehungsweise man halt anhand der gravitation
da gab's eine und dann auch,
in der lage ja auch war dort genau hinzuschauen weil der dritte punkt mittlerweile existierte neben dem lego und ja dann
wusste man hatte man erstmalig auch die bestätigung dass diese theorie auch hinhaut das heißt,
das sind im prinzip die drei presst kammern unsere,
atomaren gemengelage ja der normale stern der alles bis eisen erzeugen kann die super nora die dann bis was gibt's da eine größe die grenze auch so klar,
in einer super nova passieren kann das hängt einfach von der größe des sterns ab in dem moment also da könnt ihr auch mal gold bei rausfallen oder ist es wird.
Ja wahrscheinlich nicht aber es gibt elemente die kommen so super von kilo nova wie sogar von einem kleinen stern oder das verhältnis ist dann ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Aber super nova macht kein gold.
Macht kein gold.
Okay das weiß man ok also dafür brauchen wir dann die neue drohne sterne also diese extrem in sich zusammen gefallenen sterne und wenn die dann aufeinander treffen guter,
dann haben wir sozusagen alles was das perioden system hergibt ich finde das irgendwie sehr erstaunlich dass,
wir auf dieser erde ja eigentlich auch stimmt das eigentlich nahezu alles finden was wir auch im all sehen können.
Elemente oder natürlich.
Das heißt man kann eigentlich auch irgendwie davon ausgehen dass das bei anderen planeten auch so ist oder ist das eher zufall.
Nein ich glaube das ist nicht zufall das ist so.
Das heißt das ganze universum ist so dermaßen durchmischt und durch durch durch aber millionen von explosionen,
schon eine einzige suppe von allem was das universum hergibt alles ist über.
Oder und wir wissen ja nicht ob das direkt von einer super super war dann in einem kleineren stern war und wie es von dort haben,
das sind einfach unsere das ist unsere idee,
unsere vorfahren sind sind diese stirn kategorien und da haben wir von allen.
Wenn man jetzt diese beobachtung macht also die massen spektrum meter,
die jetzt an bord dieses raumsonde waren toto ähnliches kam er dann zum einsatz auch bei der beobachtung des jury kometen ich sag jetzt nicht den ganzen namen bei stolper jedes mal darüber auf rosita,
wo also wie lässt sich denn diese beobachtung diese chemische beobachtung
noch machen also ein beispiel haben sie ja schon genannt das einmal teleskop wo es auch vom boden ausgemacht wird an an welchen orten finden sich noch solche analyse methoden mit der man wirklich vom feststellen kann okay was,
was ist da draußen und worum handelt es sich konkret.
Wenn sie das material sterben haben,
dann wird das abkühlen und dann wird's reagieren und moleküle geben das ist dann die astro chemie und die gibt es in an verschiedenen orten sie können das im dunklen wolken beobachten mit radio teleskope,
zum beispiel sie können es beobachten dort wo stürme geboren werden,
passiert und dann können sie wieder beobachten nach der entstehung der sterns bei der planeten entstehung scheiben,
das machen sie alles mit vorwiegend info radio,
warum können sie vom boden zum teil können sie es auch nur vom weltall weil unsere atmosphäre das verhindert dass wir das sehen wir sehen uns,
und dann können sie natürlich im sonnensystem zu den verschiedenen objekten hinfliegen und das vor ort.
Welche raum gestützten teleskope kommen denn am wesentlichen zum einsatz derzeit.
Ich kenne die alten besser hören wein ein hervorragendes,
im moment.
Aber noch ein bisschen und dann das teleskop sollte oder warten wir jetzt schon ein bisschen oder.
Ja hat sich etwas verzögert.
Dass es dann in der lage eis zu analysieren,
oder die meisten können nur die personalisieren und nicht die.
Ja da sind alle schon in in ehrfurcht dass wenn dieses teleskop dann wirklich mal gestartet und in betrieb genommen wird dann hat es glaub ich auch so ziemlich alles eine erhebliche auswirkung in der raumfahrt und raum forschung gibt's glaube ich.
Das glaube ich schon also wenn wenn es funktioniert dann wäre.
Funktioniert ja das wollen wir doch mal hoffen.
Wenn man jetzt mal so zeigen diesen diesen immer währenden zyklus haben wir jetzt quasi immer nur auf sterne und diese diese extrem ereignisse der stern explosion oder fusion,
geschaut aber wenn man jetzt sich bilder anschaut,
des universums sowie habe das vorzüglich liefert dann gibt's ja nicht nur sehr viele sterne sah es gibt auch diese nebel diese bereiche nebel sind oft einfach auch nur sehr viele sterne aber
es gibt ja auch wirklich diese diese bereiche wo sterne überhaupt erstmal entstehen.
Oder es gibt eben die dunklen das ist bevor.
Bevor irgendwas ist genau da wollte ich jetzt eigentlich darauf hin so was ist da wo erstmal kein stern,
ist also wie muss man sich quasi die die diese beschaffenheit des universums derzeit so vorstellen wenn man sagt immer so ja im weltall da ist ja nichts und totales,
wenn dem so wäre gar nichts also irgendwas muss ja irgendwo sein aber war was ist sozusagen,
meistens da wo kein stern ist was findet man dort.
Also das universum ist natürlich überhaupt nicht leer es hat eigentlich überall wasserstoff.
Und medium im dünsten gebiet haben wir immer noch zehn hoch vier teilchen pro kubikmeter,
definitiv nicht leer und,
wenn es dann ein bisschen dichter wird als irgendwelchen statistischen schwankungen dichte schwankungen dann bilden sich dann eben gerne solche wolken die bestehen aus staub,
der staub entsteht wenn ein stern stirbt,
fühlt sich das material ab und dann kein stauben stehen also es ist eigentlich auch schon einmal aber ein einmaliger dass bei relativ hohen temperaturen existieren kann zum beispiel.
Kann man davon ausgehen dass er eigentlich,
das meiste material schon irgendwie,
in moleküle form also in kombination mit anderen atom vorliegt oder ist eigentlich so reines material vorher.
Im interesse hat schon relativ viel im,
aber es hat eben diesen staub.
Weil es einfach alles kontaminiert ist von vierzehn milliarden jahren explosion okay.
Und eben wenn sich diese staub körner zusammenfinden auch wieder durch gravitation gibt das dunkle wolken und die sind extrem kaufen.
Ich kann denn in dieser kälte alles so können können diese ganzen moleküle sich in dieser kälte überhaupt so ohne weiteres bilden wie man das von der erde her kennt.
Das ist etwas dass man erst seit kurzem weiss dass das geht,
ihnen sagen das geht nicht sie brauchen aktivierung energie,
sie brauchen mindestens energie um zu organisieren dann geht's ohne energie barriere,
aber man hat gemerkt dass an den oberflächen diese kirmes politische chemie funktionieren.
Das heisst sitzt ein atom ab zum beispiel ein sauerstoff sitzt auf diesen staub karten und dann kommt ein wasserstoff,
und dann kann das durch den tunnel effekte mechanische tunnel effekte miteinander agieren wirtschaft oberfläche dieses stadt.
Also durch die pure nähe.
Und dann haben wir sie dann haben sie schon dann kommt noch ein wasserstoff und dann hatten sie.
Und so wird gebildet auf diesen staub,
in den dunklen wolken auf die temperaturen das verbieten.
Und mittlerweile wissen wir dass das schon relativ komplexe moleküle geben.
Was heißt relativ komplex.
In der gastronomie ist ein komplexes moleküle dass mindestens sechs atome hat und ein kohlenstoff das sind komplett gar nicht.
Botschaft muss aber dabei sein.
Ein kohlenstoff und fünf andere stoffe mindestens sechs dome und mindestens ein.
Okay das heißt das ist das was da draußen so rum war er sagte sie dadurch statistische verteilung also
und würde jetzt mein ist ja alles gleichmäßig verteilt,
aber irgendwann ist es dann halt auch mal zufällig nicht gleichmäßig verteilt in dem moment entsteht so ein ungleichgewicht das wiederum dazu führt dass halt die gravitation sich stärker ausgeprägt als es normalerweise tut
und dann die dinge irgendwie zueinander kommen sich gegenseitig anziehen und dann so eine art,
sag mal sagen so eine verklumpen sozusagen bewirken dass dieser,
mehr oder weniger gleichmäßig verteilt die staub eben nicht mehr so gleichmäßig verteilt ist und das hat er dann so diese kettenreaktion dass wenn erstmal irgendwo was dichter ist dann hat es ja wieder mehr gravitation was dann wiederum andere teile an zieht etcetera,
wie geht dieser prozess dann üblicherweise weiter was weiß man darüber.
Oder diese wolken können dann im prinzip zu schwer werden also gravitation überwiegt dann und dann können sie kollabieren,
und dann bekommen sie gebiete wo sterne stern bildung möglich ist wenn die dichte hoch genug wird dann können sich sterne bildet.
Ist ganz schön schnell von irgendwie da sind so ein paar kleine partikel und dann bildet sich gleich so im stern,
es ist ja ist es dann immer ein stern oder muss man quasi so,
ist eigentlich eigentlich immer gleich auch automatisch an sternen system was dabei entsteht.
Also entstehen meistens viele sterne wenn eine sache sind risiko riesig wenn die kollabieren,
wird es an verschiedenen orten dicht genug dass ein stern sich bilden kann das material,
und also haben wir am meistens stellenangebote geboten von mehreren sterben und was wir heute wissen meistens bilden sich dann auch die plane.
Und das ist auch eine gute erklärung dafür warum wir so viele doppel sternen.
Genau genau.
Thema zum beispiel aussehen also es ist jetzt nicht so die ausnahme man für uns ist das natürlich total mystisch ort zwei sonnen und so aber,
kommt relativ oft vor und es ist jetzt auch nicht so überraschend wenn man da mal so drüber nachdenken na ja okay also das wenn sich irgendwo ein sternen bildet
dann ist eigentlich auch genug material für weitere dabei die frage ist immer nur reicht's dann aus erinnere mich ja irgendwann,
auch mal über den saturn gesprochen der irgendwie auch,
sehr groß ist viele monday,
hätte auch hätte auch zu 'ner sonne gereicht hat halt ein bisschen was,
gefehlt und so ist es dann halt nur ein weiterer planet geworden.
Diese dunklen wolken die sind absolut riesig das ist ein vielfaches des sonnensystems an masse.
Das ist nicht nur ein kleines gebildet das ist riesig und damit genügend material vorhanden für einen stern oder für viele sterne die neuen gerissen und.
Ausstattung natürlich aber so stellt man sich vor dass sterne geboren werden.
Solchen beobachtungen sprechen reden wir da jetzt im wesentlichen von beobachtung in unserer eigenen galaxie oder äh sind wir auch in der lage über die milchstraße hinaus solche beobachtungen zu machen.
Ja wir sind ja nicht viele sterne außerhalb unsere milchstraße dann sind wir immer gerade ganze galaxien die sind sehr weit.
Darüber kann man in dem sinne gar nicht solche aussagen treffen das heißt es jetzt.
Ja ja aber dann zu nehmen dass das überall passiert.
Aber er kann es nur so inspirieren sozusagen aus dem also wesentlichen der beobachtung traum ist die milchstraße.
Genau genau genau.
Für solche betrachtung.
Jetzt hat man keinen direkten zugriff.
Aber man nimmt an dass kometen eigentlich noch am besten reflektieren was was damals war bevor es sich die sonne gewinnt.
Warum nimmt man das an.
Weil kometen die kommentare bis heute hat da weiß man die sind so bei uranus nett und entstanden das ist weit weg von der sonne und sind ja dann hinaus gekriegt worden.
Sind seite eigentlich immer da draußen bis sie dann mit einem klick erhalten und reinkommen,
die periode zwischen kometen zu ein kurz bei radio tischen oder die kommen natürlich nicht so häufig nicht so viel da kann man schon häufig aber nicht so oft weil die verlieren material,
die sind ja nicht grosse vier kilometer ungefähr prozent des materials verloren,
das heisst gibt.
Bei null komma eins prozent bei diesem durchlauf an der sonne pro umlauf quasi.
Das heißt es gibt.
Schauen sie mal rum und alles ist weg.
Ja ja so ungefähr und wahrscheinlich gibt's den vorher nicht mehr weil wir dann thermisch instabil und und bricht auseinander und dann geht's sehr schnell.
Warum haben wir eigentlich immer gut tiefgefroren.
Und das erklärt jetzt auch nochmal dieses große interesse,
für diese disziplin gerade an kometen weil man einfach weiß das ist halt das material,
vermutlich im wesentlichen so wie es war als sich unsere planeten in unserem sonnensystem gebildet haben.
Genau genau.
Und jetzt die aufgabe von rauszufinden woher stammt das material ursprünglich wieviel vom ursprünglichen material ist übrig geblieben,
wie hat es sich verändert bei der bildung des kometen der planet ein system und was was sehen wir eben noch vom ursprünglichen bei diesem mann.
Was war ihre rolle bei bei der rose mission über toto hat man ja schon kurz gesprochen im prinzip nochmal das gleiche in grün oder war das so eine andere ausgabe.
Also bei rosinen massen meter das hier in der schweiz gebaut wurde aber mithilfe von deutschland frankreich belgien und den usa,
weil ich zuerst mal.
Rosita spektrum meter vor analysis das heißt rosin.
Mit dem instrument haben wir auch neutral gemessen millionen sondern vor allem neutral,
zuerst projektmanager habe das ganze zusammengebracht oder die vielen interface ist mit unseren kollegen und industrie gemeinsam mit reza,
dann mein chef funktioniert zweitausenddrei professor und nachher habe ich die leitung übernommen prinzipiell investor von,
verantwortlich für das instrument.
Aber überhaupt sehr viel personelle kontinuität zwischen diesen beiden projekten zwischen toto und rosita.
Bei uns ja sonst eben nicht oder nein hat er die meisten leute die bei schotter dabei waren sind ältere und früher als geschieden.
Okay aber dann die nachfolger kam sozusagen.
Glücklicherweise damals noch relativ jung und dann hab ich bei der missionen mitgemacht.
Aber viele institute die sozusagen schon bei.
Institute schon ja ja ja das sind das sind so plus minus dergleichen.
Okay es war ja die ausbeute bei otto überschaubar
na haben wir gerade angerissen so da war noch nicht so viel möglich das war ein kurz,
das projekt man hat die gelegenheit ergriffen das ist möglich war
spannende geschichte ist ja auch einiges schief gegangen
dann war ja im prinzip wetter die möglichkeit okay jetzt kann man alles nochmal richtig machen jetzt haben wir schon viel gelernt jetzt wissen wir auch mehr worauf ihr eigentlich schauen wollen und der katalog von dingen die untersucht worden im rahmen dieser mission war ja
extrem groß als nochmal diese chemische,
cosmos chemische perspektive nehmen mit dem rosine instrument was war,
was war das ziel was was wollen sie herausfinden konkret und vor allem was wohl.
Also wir hatten natürlich von daher ganz klar sehr viele offene fragen an den kommen,
zum beispiel das wasser das wasser des wassers wir haben bei gefunden dass kometen wie,
nicht verantwortlich sein können für unser wasser die hat man nicht drüber eingestimmt.
Was hat er da nicht über eingestimmt.
Auf der erde haben sie etwa jedes zehntausendsten wassermoleküle ist dekoriert hat ein territorium statt ein wasserstoff ostern und beim kometen dreimal mehr.
Das ist ein eindeutiges indiz dass das nicht die quelle sein.
Das genau genau sonst hätten wir hier auf der erde auch mehr.
Aber um das zu verstehen was was kann denn dafür sorgen dass dieser,
dorothee anteil anders ist also man würde ja erwarten wenn sich überall alles auf dieselbe art und weise bildet müssen sich ja auch wasser eigentlich überall in ich bin ist das dann quasi etwas was sich später einstellt oder andere.
Es ist das ist jetzt wirklich sie bilden wasser raus wasserstoff und sauerstoff es gibt eine reaktion für schlussendlich zu wasser,
und bei der chemie haben sie immer auch die rückwärts reaktion,
wasser wasserstoff sauerstoff und die reaktionszeit raten wie lange das geht bei welcher temperatur,
die ist anders für das als für wasserstoff,
und so können sie je nach temperatur wo sie das wasser bilden,
mehr im fertigen wasserkraftanlage oder weniger.
Im prinzip unser sonnensystem hat sehr wenig leute ihre um das ist nur ein teil in hunderttausend im wasser haben wir,
das ist oder weil diese reaktion gut funktioniert dass man das wasser anlage.
Das heißt es ist eigentlich eine eine eigenschaft unseres sonnensystems dass wir diese art und weise von wasser haben mit dieser verteilung dieser art fingerabdruck ist für den ort.
Für die physikalischen bedingungen unter der das was gebildet wurde die temperatur formen.
Okay aber das würde er dann bedeuten dass dieser komet von woanders ist.
Nein das heraus gebildet wurde.
Also im sinne von.
Dort ist ja kalter.
Ok also es geht hier um die bereiche des sonnensystems wo es sich.
Genau.
Und die vermutung oder eine der vermutung war ja das wasser auf der erde überhaupt erst später dazu gekommen ist ich freue mich eigentlich auch noch warum auch gleich nochmal diskutieren aber wo kommts her und,
ist damit diese theorie der kometen jetzt schon komplett,
gestorben oder ist es nur dass die aus der wolke nicht mehr dazu.
Wir haben eben bei schotter haben wir das ganz klar gezeigt dass das nicht sein können und dann war natürlich die große frage können bitte familienkarte sein die aus dem gürtel stammen.
Da kommt der touri her.
Na ja da kommt aber auch zwei und halb zwei konnte man mit.
Vom space ausmessen und der hat ein irdische es verhältnis für das deutsche,
und dann und dann hat man gesagt ja jetzt wissen wir es nicht,
und dann.
Ich konnte nicht beobachtet werden von herrscher war.
Nein nein ja der ist auch klein klein und aktiv.
Und dann haben wir das was dann beim zürich gemessen und gesehen dass es noch viel extremen ist aus harry und das definitiv comedy-video können,
und was wir ja einfach gesehen haben kometen haben ein breiten bereich wurden wahrscheinlich eben nicht alle am gleichen gebildet.
Unabhängig davon was sie sich heute aufhalten.
Das heißt das war eigentlich wie sagt man immer so schön es gibt ja keine es gibt ja keine
misslungenen versuche also was auch immer man man macht man gewinnt immer irgendwelche erkenntnisse mindestens über die eigene technik,
wenn sie da mal nicht so funktioniert,
das heißt diese frage ist eigentlich nach wie vor unbeantwortet wo das wasser herkommt man kann nur sagen es sind nicht auf jeden fall kometen aus.
Wir haben mittlerweile daten von etwa zwölf kilometer,
drei sondern etwa zwölf die meisten vom boden geschützten beobachtungen und der mittelwert ist weit über dem wert den wir hier auf der erde haben und damit können wir wahrscheinlich kommentare,
die beiden theorien die übrig bleiben eines die haben einen waschen kein um das kompatibel ist mit unserer reihe.
Das andere ist dass die erde ihrem wasser selber behalten haben.
Was ja sozusagen immer das war wo ich mich immer gefragt habe,
warum muss es denn von woanders kommen vielleicht war es ja schon immer da es ist jetzt so nicht so dass es jetzt nicht es gibt auf den maßen aufm boden überall gibt's wasser warum soll es nicht auf der erde dann auch schon immer wasser in der entsprechende menge gegeben haben.
Also was wir halt wissen die erste wahl heißt am anfang zweihundertfünfzig grad celsius da hat es kein wasser oberfläche,
und sie hatte ja diesen monat im pakt grosse planet zusammengeschlossen ist und darf entfernt garantiert alles oberflächen.
Aber aber nicht unbedingt natürlich das wasser,
und es gibt wissenschaftler die behaupten es gäbe sogar einen wasser vom tiefen mantel an die oberfläche und wieder zurück mit einer periode von einer milliarde,
so kann man sich erklären vielleicht dass das wasser von unten kommt.
Warum ist man sich so sicher dass das wasser an der oberfläche bei dem zusammenstoß auf jeden fall weg ist ich meine,
ja dann im schlimmsten fall immer noch so in dem eigenen orbit um die sonne herum und hätte ja dann.
Nein nein einnehmen.
Eingesammelt werden können.
Einen pakt der größenordnung von von diesem mond vor allem,
montag impakt der muss das was der hat die ganze atmosphäre.
Ja wo ist sie denn dann hin das wird ja nicht.
Also das hat garantierte die frucht geschwindigkeit erreicht das material das ist einfach.
Okay also es ist einfach einfach weg.
Einfach weg viel oder wir haben an der oberfläche nur.
So ein kleiner tropfen ja das ist immer schön wenn man sich so eine visualisierung anschaut so größe der erde und wie groß wäre jetzt sozusagen die erde wenn sie nur aus dem wasser besteht was sie hat und das ist so ein kleiner tropfen der irgendwie dann
ist das ist relativ wenig kann man sich dann wiederum ganz gut vorstellen dass du so so eine menge wasser auch im im erdbeeren hätte überleben.
Heute wissen wir glaube ich dass das mehr oder weniger kritisch und die haben so zwischen zwei und fünf prozent waffen.
Das heißt unsere hätte längst genug das wieder zu bringen.
Das heißt man könnte jetzt so laienhaft sagen okay also man hat sich die kometen die theoretisch selten vorbeibringen können angeschaut da kommt's wahrscheinlich her,
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es einfach innerhalb der erde geschlummert ist und durch diesen aufprall zwar was weggeflogen ist aber dann eben auch sehr viel wiederum von innen freigesetzt wurde das hand und fuß hat haben könnte.
Ich bin nicht geologie und von daher bin ich immer vorsichtig aber es leuchtet das möchten wir nicht wahnsinnig ein aus der rede haben hatten sich am anfang viel mehr wasser als heute.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht so viele kommen,
und dann brauchen sie einen neuen viele einschläge um das wasser zu bringen und bei jedem einschlag passiert das oder sie bringen zwei material aber sie entfernen auch wieder und wenn sie sehr sehr viele einschläge brauchen dann am schluss entfernen sie mir auf sie bringen.
Das ist so aber ich bin auch.
Ja gut aber das klingt ja.
Meinen das passt nicht.
Aber was schön ist wir wissen auch wie viel kommentare kommen,
es ist längst nicht alles aber jetzt jetzt kann man wieder die die vorläufe sterben die atome machen,
die machen je nach ob es eine super oder ein kilo machen die verschiedene so toben verhältnisse,
das sind das sind atome die haben die gleichen chemischen eigenschaften die gleichen anfang proton verschiedene drohnen.
Das heißt daraus ergibt sich 'ne andere masse aber kein anderes chemisches.
Genau verhalten richtig.
Deswegen ist halt auch wasser mit dem interior ist verhält sich immer noch wie ein normales wasser aber man kann's quasi wiegen und stellt fest ist schwerer.
Jetzt bei den das macht keine chemie.
Das hat das kommt den neuen varianten vor vom masse hundertvierundzwanzig bis hundertsechzig,
und die menge jedes tops dies das ist dein fingerabdruck woher es kommt,
da kommt ein teil kommt von super koalitionen sterben wir unsere sonne das kommt von frau herkommen aber die verteilung diese über die maßen,
ist je nach vorläufer stern verschiedene.
Das geht jetzt nur funktionieren oder es geht generell für alle.
Das ist einfach gut weil es neun hat oder viele haben null eins zwei.
Ja das viel varianz drin.
Genau kann man viel variante dann kann man ein bisschen unterscheiden und das komische bei unserer erde ist dass in unseren atmosphäre das gesehen und nicht dem gesehen ohne mindern.
Der fingerabdruck.
Das ist nicht solar- entspricht nicht sonne entspricht nicht,
sondern es anders und seit vierzig jahren mehr als vierzig jahren hat man versucht zu finden wieso das in unserer atmosphäre.
Welches kino ist es denn mit wieviel.
Eine mischung von vorläufer einen ganz kleinen fingerabdruck,
und seit dem messungen von rosinen wissen wir,
dass es kompatibel ist mit ungefähr zweiundzwanzig prozent sendung vom kometen,
wenn sie das mischen da kriegen sie exakt dem fingerabdruck,
atmosphärisch.
Nochmal wenn ich was mische das.
Zweiundzwanzig prozent kommt mit achtundsiebzig prozent genau.
Er hat inneres ergibt unsere atmosphäre was wiederum dafür sprechen könnte dass so ein komet auf der erde eingeschlagen ist und sich dadurch gemischt hat.
Also das heisst wahrscheinlich dass komedien eingeschlagen habe oder längst nicht so viel dass das das wasser.
Und man kann dann aber gesehen und.
Vielleicht.
Dann kann man ausrechnen wieviele kometen brauchen sie um das zu bringen und wie viel wasser bringen die gleichzeitig oder mit einem gesehen und wir wissen ja wie viel wasser,
es hat dem kommen,
und dann können sie ausrechnen und dann kommen sie zum schluss das vielleicht ein promille bis maximum ein prozent der serbischen was,
wenn sie zweiundzwanzig prozent des gesehen uns liefern.
Ja ja.
Und damit können sie nachher ausrechnen wie viel organische materialien die kometen gebracht haben zu der zeit weil wir wissen wie viele organische material wir im kometen haben relativ zum gesehen und,
und dann kommen sie darauf dass mehrfach die heutige biomasse von kometen geliefert.
Das heißt das ganze ist eigentlich so 'ne art detektiv,
was da so rum kreucht und fleucht und eben nicht nur welche elemente an sich,
dort vorhanden sind sondern eben auch konkret in welcher ausprägung welcher mischung all diese ganzen,
regung und versucht das alles in relation,
auf anderen himmelskörper in beobachtung et cetera hat,
puh das ist ja relativ komplex aber dann nochmal kurz auf die ergebnisse von dem rosinen instrument also bei der rosita mission schauen,
wie komplex ist denn der komet letztlich rein chemisch ist da sehr viel mehr gefunden worden als man dachte weniger.
Nein nein es ist extrem komplex form haben wir eben sehr viel organische materialien gefunden wir haben zum beispiel so lange kohlenstoff ketten gefunden bis zu,
sieben acht kohlenstoff wir haben ein euro magische moleküle gefunden als pensionen auf berlin das sind dringend,
wir haben alkohol gefunden besser,
kohlenstoff vertonen verschiedene alkohol.
Es gibt alkohol auf.
Ja es gibt auch ethanol also den rest würden sie lieber nicht trinken aber er hat's aber haben sehr früh herausgefunden dass der comic stinkt.
Also müsste wenn man ihn hier parken würde dann würde stinken.
Und zwar schrecklich das nachgestellt das stinkt wirklich es hat.
Ach wir haben sozusagen dass all das was man sozusagen in der zusammensetzung vorgefunden hat einfach mal gemischt und mal geguckt was da sozusagen.
Gemischt ja ja ein kollege von uns hat das in england dann auf postkarten ein verbleibt oder das kann man so.
Ach so dass man diese ein duftet oder.
Genau dass man die einen dürften und ich kann ihnen sagen kiste bekommen die ist bei mir im büro gestanden aber nicht lange.
Okay.
Das stinkt wird oder es hat das recht,
alle möglichen dinge die stinken es hat sehr viel schwefel haltigen dinge die andere stinken.
Ist es nur unangenehm oder ist es auch giftig in dem sinne für uns.
Es wäre giftig wenn es in genügenden konzentration wäre aber die konzentration in der atmosphäre des kompetent ist klein oder das sind nicht überleben sie schon.
Das heißt das stinken ist eigentlich eher auch eine reaktion unseres körpers dass er merkt so,
wenn du davon zu viel nimmst ist nicht gut für dich okay gut ne das ist ja auch keine schlechte reaktion.
Genau richtig ja naja aber so ein bisschen der höhepunkt von komplexität war dann die aminosäuren sind wir haben minus gefunden auf dem kommen.
Kein leben definitiv nicht alles viel zu kalt auf den kometen aber die tatsache dass aminosäure entsteht ohne zutun eine ohne zu tun sonnensystems ist schon sehr bedeutungsvoll.
Und so kann es sein dass komedie neben mit dem gesehen und ein bisschen wasser.
Diese organische moleküle gebracht haben auf die erde und dass das vielleicht eine auslöser war dass sich leben.
Aminosäuren sind ja wenn ich das richtig verstehe die die basis der proteine und die proteine sind sozusagen die basis von so ziemlich alles was in unserem körper so,
abgeht so also ohne proteine läuft da mal überhaupt nix und spricht man kann sagen in dem moment wo sich aminosäuren irgendwo bilden ist eine grundlage geschaffen um,
theoretisch ein leben so wie wir es jetzt definieren als leben ja das hat quasi unsere menschliche manuel jede sicht der dinge,
kann durchaus sein dass auch noch andere varianten gibt nur kennen wir die eben nicht dass sie damit sozusagen geschaffen ist,
sprich wenn schon auf einem kometen der eigentlich die ganze zeit nur im kältesten regionen wo man nicht passiert ja also es ist ja quasi wirklich das absolute dorf da draußen,
wenn sich dort im prinzip schon alles bilden kann was es braucht,
ist das alles was man braucht also fehlt auch noch irgendwas essentielles was hat man da irgendwas nicht gefunden von dem man sagt so also wenn er wenn das nicht dabei ist dann läuft das alles nicht.
Nein wir haben auch zum beispiel hat man zum ersten mal gefunden hat ist ebenfalls absoluten lebensnotwendig von unser körper wird es nicht funktionieren hat man auch beim kometen gefunden wir haben,
das ist jetzt vielleicht der nachteil unserer forschung,
wir haben ganz viele male kühle gefunden die als sogenannte biomarkt gelten als zeichen dass es dort leben haben,
herzhaften comedian aber kein leben ich sag's nochmal leben aber die biomarkt sind dort,
das heißt wenn sie jetzt einen planeten außerhalb unseres sonnensystems anschauen und sie sehen diese moleküle sagt ihnen das überhaupt nicht dass es dort leben,
es wird dank der forschung wird es viel schwieriger werden eindeutig sagen zu können auf diesem planeten hat's leben.
Aber wenn wir jetzt den kometen so nehmen würde man würde eine dicke heiz lampe einfach darüber halten also wenn das sozusagen das einzige problem ist würde sich dann zwangsläufig da etwas entwickeln oder.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen also,
meiner meinung nach wenn sie den kometen ins meer werfen dann schmilzt er die moleküle werden beweglich sie können reagieren mit dem flüssigen wasser,
und aber beim mehr wird sich das sehr schnell verdünnen dass es bekommen keine großen konzentrationen oder nur für sehr kurze zeit,
aber wenn sie den kometen entweder in einer,
kleineren tempo werfen tun hier bei bayern dann können sie sehr schnell eine hohe konzentration an organische moleküle erzeugen,
und das kann dann mit dem wasser flüssig wasser und mit den mineralien die es auch braucht,
reagieren und so eventuell zu leben führen es gibt gibt der wissenschaftler die schreiben über kometen tempo,
ein großes meer wahrscheinlich eher kleinere tümpel also die kometen selber bringt wasser mit vielleicht reicht auch schon aber es braucht wahrscheinlich in kontakt zu treten,
mineralien.
Die jetzt auf dem kopf so nicht fahren.
Ja es hat schon mineralien.
Und die idee ist ein bisschen dass eben nicht nur reinkommen eingeschlagen hat vielleicht hunderttausend so,
und dass sich leben an verschiedensten leuten kommen zu entwickeln und das meiste war für mich oder ist gerade wieder ausgestorben eines hat sich durchgesetzt und da müsst ihr das leben auf dreht,
ist alles gleich in der gleichen.
Es gab doch mal dieses schöne experiment mit der suppe wo im prinzip eigentlich nur so ein,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau was drin war wasser mit irgendwelchen elementen einfach nur der strahlung ausgesetzt wurde und sich dann dort eigentlich auch alles gebildet hat was man braucht.
Ja ich meine aber das ist genau das was beim kometen auch passiert ist eben in dieser.
Aber der bräuchte es ja noch nicht mal trotzdem noch nicht mal den kometen.
Ja aber wir machen es auf der karte also sie brauchen sich mal schon wasser.
Ja aber ja festgestellt ist äh quasi in im schwamm einmal kurz ausgedrückt worden und dann waren die teiche voll so dann kommt die strahlung und haut da mal ordentlich drauf alle anderen materialien sind ja vorhanden.
Nee nicht wirklich im wasser.
Kann es sich einfach aus sicht.
Nein also es gibt eine andere theorie leben entwickelt hat den kometen ist dass es so voll kanarische,
aktivität ist im meer das gibts oder wir wissen es gibt diese unterwasser und dort kommen die richtigen dinge raus.
Aber ich glaube das problem dort ist auch sie kriegen die konzentration nicht hin weil es mir nicht stetig oder das bewegt sich das zeug,
in relativ kurz.
Ja gut aber es kann ja auch ein vulkan unter einem see gewesen sein wo sich eben nicht so extrem könnte.
Könnte er könnte ja ich glaube da ist das letzte wort nicht gesprochen.
Spekulieren herum aber darum geht's ja im prinzip nicht diese ganzen theorien überhaupt erstmal aufzustellen auch einfach um etwas zu haben mit dem man spielen kann so mit was was was wollen wir denn jetzt sozusagen als nächstes eigentlich beantwortet bekommen.
Oder meine theorie von entweder kometen im meer das war schon vorhanden und jetzt mit der seite da haben wir eigentlich viele argumente die schon für kometen sprechen,
ganz einfach weil es die komplexen moleküle gibt die gibt's nicht beim volk die müssen sie zuerst machen.
Das heißt es ist sozusagen so 'ne art ausgelagert des entstehung labor weil dann komischer,
die prozesse sehr viel effizienter ablaufen können oder konzentrierter ablaufen können oder mehr zeit haben.
Sie haben mehr zeit.
Einfach mehr zeit ohne dass ich alles die ganze zeit ändert.
Ja ja genau genau ja ja sie haben lange lange zeit haben sie die gleichen konditionen.
So ein bisschen so die die petry schale im alter,
kurve und wo sich das alles so ein bisschen entwickeln kann und dann fällt es halt irgendwann auf die erde drauf und beschleunigt,
diesen prozess oder setzt ihr überhaupt erstmalig in gang was auch eine interessante das fiktive darauf.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz,
diese frage nach dem leben also ich habe das gefühl diese ganze hatten ja schon erwähnt astro chemie ist im prinzip eigentlich erstmal so entdeckt worden so grade in den letzten
zehn zwanzig jahren hört man mehr davon und tut sich auch universitären mir das auch entsprechende institute und spezialisierte studien,
gänge gibt es gab auch schon so die eine oder andere aufregung da gab's mal diese etwas schief gelaufen der nasa veröffentlichung wenn ich mich richtig erinnere wo,
eine neue form des lebens angeblich gefunden worden sein stellte sich aber raus das war aus welchen gründen auch immer eine ente,
diese unsere sicht des,
das dessen was leben ist meine das ist ja schon erwähnt und unsere selbstwahrnehmung wie wir wissen ja was leben ist weil wir definieren das was was was wir sind als leben,
und die frage ist ja kann es auch,
die nicht unsere form des lebens ist also diese variante hat sich halt auf der erde so durchgesetzt aber das heißt ja nicht unbedingt dass es nicht auf anderen planeten auch anders sein könnte sind wir überhaupt in der lage sowas zu entdecken bevor es anfängt und zu sprechen.
Was ist eine gute frage oder im prinzip als unser leben ist auf kohlenstoff passiert und braucht flüssig wasser.
Was ich mein wasser ist ein ganz spezieller stoff also auch chemisch gesehen hat dann moment und verhält sich dann wirklich anders als die meisten anderen moleküle,
und die gibt es nicht wie sand am meer speziell wasser wasser,
ist zentral das glaube ich schon hingegen kohlenstoff sie könnten auch sie nehmen ist auch fertig chemisch gesehen,
man könnte sich das vorstellen es gibt wahrscheinlich andere möglichkeiten die frage ist halt nur wenn wir das zulassen,
wir suchen wir nachdem wir suchen wir noch etwas von dem ihr überhaupt keine ahnung haben wir's aussieht,
das ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich hoffnungslos also die philosophen sagen es weiter seine neue spannende frage wie sucht man etwas von dem man nicht weiß.
Das mag sein aber um vielleicht bei den den gedanken also wissen durchzuspielen auch selber mal noch ein bisschen besser zu verstehen,
was wir denn jetzt eigentlich quasi,
was eigentlich so das besondere ist dieser lebens entstehung also klar wasser und kohlenstoff ist so die basis fall mehr oder weniger alles was quasi bei uns relevant ist,
sind verbindungen davon ist das richtig obwohl natürlich bestimmte elemente auch präsent sein müssen um,
wie entsprechende prozesse überhaupt in gegangen zu erhalten fußball hat mir schon,
erwähnt eisen et cetera also ganzen müssen präsent sein aber sie nicht unbedingt teil,
moleküle wählt aus der sich das macht und der pfad geht dann zu diesem aminosäuren die dann die proteine bilden,
die sind eigentlich so im wesentlichen der der schlüssel weil diese.
Bremen komplexen moleküle verbindung,
alles mögliche erschließen im wahrsten sinne des wortes weil sie sind der schlüssel für alle prozesse die in unserem körper abgeben das heißt,
was wir eigentlich suchen ist eine kombination von von elementen die sich chemisch zusammen tun kann aber dir auch diesen wunderbaren part einschlagen kann so ein komplexes regelwerk aus sich selbst heraus zu entwickeln,
können wir auch sagen dann simulieren wir das mal,
durch aber das ist wahrscheinlich schwierig weil einfach die kombination zu zu groß sind aber gibt's denn zumindest andere bereiche wo man so erste schritte schon gesehen hat dass man schon sieht okay es gab hier,
das mag sich chemisch alles auch sehr gerne hat aber jetzt nichts mit wasser und kohlenstoff primär zu tun weil es zumindest eins davon weg und hat auch irgendwie so eine gewisse komplexität auch wenn sie noch nicht anfängt zu zucken und zu laufen.
Es gibt also meine definiert man leben oder ein,
dass man sich produziert und es gibt mineralien die reproduzieren.
Reproduzieren und trotzdem ist es nicht leben oder also so einzelne notwendige konditionen verleben die findet man schon man findet einfach die kombination.
Auch für unser leben und wir haben noch keine hinreichende definitionen gefunden für uns.
Wir wissen wir müssen energie umsatz machen wir müssen reproduzieren und so weiter aber das alles reichen noch nicht am leben zu definieren es gibt keine definition verliebt.
Da so eine sichtweise.
Es gibt so eine sichtweise eben wir haben das haben wir mit den theologen herstellen,
mit dem philosophen für mich war noch das beste der philosoph der gesagt hat leben ist ein konzept,
dass wir kennen an den auswirkungen des hat,
in der physik kann man viele konzepte oder zum beispiel kraft der begriff kraft das ist auch ein konzept das merkt man wenn die ausgeübt wird dann merkt man aber im prinzip ein begriff der nicht.
Das leben ist auch ein besseren so wir merken überall wo leben ist an den auswirkungen des haben.
Aber das es fehlt das stimmt auch nicht.
Darum wenn wir unser leben manchmal richtig definieren können wie können wir das,
wird vielleicht kommen.
Ich will jetzt mal auf dem ganzen,
leben nicht so sehr rum reiten aber vielleicht schauen wir mal sowas an erkenntnissen,
gekommen ist jetzt gar nicht mal durch die beobachtung von wolken oder eben kometen sondern unserer unmittelbaren nachbarn die welt schon beobachtet haben also wo wir konkret auch vor ort waren sprich mond,
und maß so wie ich das mitbekommen habe ist auch die komplexität auf dem maß sehr viel umfangreicher als man sich das vielleicht vorher so,
erhofft hat wir haben ja jetzt dort nicht nur die fern beobachtung,
sondern eben mittlerweile auch so labore die herumfahren können und sogar in der lage sind selfies von sich zu schießen weil sie auch schon einen interessanten vorstoß der menschheit finde.
Was hat das beigetragen zu der astro chemischen,
forschung was sind eigentlich die fragestellung die sich jetzt insgesamt gerade aufdrängen die man beantwortet haben wir jetzt mal auch von dieser lebens.
Es ist noch ein bisschen schwierig oder wie sieht man ja eigentlich nur die oberfläche.
Und alles andere als privat das ist entwicklungsgeschichte aber anhand von mais und mund kann man eben die entwicklung des sonnensystems nicht unbedingt die bildung die entwicklung studieren.
Aber aber wie ursprünglich war wissen und werden wir auch nicht so einfach finden es sei denn wir könnten wirklich auch runter bohren und zwar relativ.
Und wir gerade gesehen haben bei dem zuletzt gescheiterten experiment bohren ist greife einfach.
Mein bohren ist gar nicht so einfach.
Zumindest da wo es versucht wurde war es nicht so so einfach.
Ja ja ja ja genau.
Aber aber die entwicklung zu sehen oder ob man jetzt noch etwas vom ursprünglichen findet.
Eventuell spuren noch eines ursprünglichen lebens dort sind da kann man sich noch mehr machen.
Ja gut.
Aber es ist eine andere frage.
Ja genau aber ich meine ich verstehe die suche nach dem ursprung und so aber ich meine auch wenn man sich die entwicklung anschaut was,
was kann man da auch irgendwas also wie ist die erkenntnis lage,
dort also ist das jetzt einfach langweilig weil es halt nur staub und alles schon so geröstet und.
Nein nein nein nein etwas wie er dann auch mal sehen wird.
Irgendwann wenn wir sie auch final außerhalb balance gebracht haben.
Wenn unsere sonne feststellen wird auch die die biologie verschwinden und dann,
sind wir ein bisschen bei maus was übrig bleibt ist auch ein blick kein fenster in die zukunft ist ein fenster wie es auf anderen planeten aussehen könnte wenn wir planeten studierenden,
für mich auch wichtig zu sehen wie wir speziell eigentlich die nehmen wir eben die anderen planeten,
wir haben hier wirklich einmalige bedingungen und an auch wenn das universum groß ist es wird nicht unendlich viele erben geben,
oder weil die bedingungen hier ist im moment absolut einmal.
Ja und vor allem ist auch absehbar das selbst wenn es irgendwo bessere bedingungen gäbe nicht so richtig die technologie haben um dort dann langfristig runterzukommen und ich glaube überhaupt meine das klingt jetzt auch aus unserem gespräch wieder deutlich heraus,
dann habe ich mal darüber nachgedacht wir machen uns glaube ich auch zu wenig klar dass wir ja selbst,
ein stück dieser erde sind diese wahrnehmung des wir hier so,
leben und wir können jetzt mal so wie im salz fältchen auch mal irgendwo anders leben,
ja da muss ja nur das fotos vor irgendwo fehlen oder nicht mehr entsprechende menge vorhanden sein dann haben wir da schon ein problem also genau diese spezifische zusammensetzung wie sie sich eben hier gefunden hat hat uns ja überhaupt erst,
hervorgebracht und wir sind ja nicht,
getrennt davon zu sehen also unser leben ist ja nicht ohne die erde also funktionieren ja im prinzip nur genauso auf dieser erde weil wir,
dafür quasi maßgeschneidert sind.
Da gebe ich ihnen völlig recht das sage ich auch immer der mensch ist für dich gemacht und kann eigentlich nirgends existieren,
neben dem das schon die physik und sagt dass wir nicht ineinander sonnensystem fliegen können in unseren achtzig jahren lebensdauer die wir haben oder.
Aber die chemie macht es einfach komplett und sagst das ist die einzige steckdose indem du dich reinsteckt.
Genau ganz genau.
Jetzt gibt es aber auch noch ein paar,
ich habe da so ein paar andere lieblinge in unserem sonnensystem die ja sagen wir mal so aus als chemische perspektive finde ich auch super interessant sind,
mal äh mal meine super lieblinge sind einerseits der titan also einen der größten mond des saturn und dann installation aus.
Jupiter oder toren außer tor ne ja also ich liebe den saturn und seine monde,
titan ein kalter mond der,
aussieht wie die erde wie wir jetzt wissen nachdem,
die äh casino mission sich das ja mal genauer angeschaut hat heute ins also die lander mission der fotos geschickt hat,
es gibt alles was ja auch gibt sehen flüsse teller delta,
tolles programm besteht aber aus etwas komplett anderem steht aus metall ammoniak all das was stinkt so trotzdem,
entfaltet es irgendwie dieselbe ideologische wunderwelt und dann so auf der anderen seite so insel atos und ein teil was um die ganze zeit riesige wasser fontänen ins weltall jagd,
was kann man beobachten aus der ferne und durch diese mission und vielleicht gibt's auch andere beispiele aber,
haben hat die beobachtung dieser objekte uns nennenswerte daten geliefert die so im chemischen bereich neue aha-momente erzeugt haben.
Also sicher die wasserstoff welt von titan.
Niemand so vorgestellt dass es diese moleküle hat dass es viele von diesen moleküle hat,
die meere machen können sehen machen können eis machen können.
Und das zeigt eben dass diese auch wieder wahrscheinlich dass diese moleküle vorhanden waren bei der entstehung von diesem titan und nicht nachher geformt wollten.
Dass die eltern ist dass unser sohn,
die meisten vom vorher stamm.
Lustig weil diese energie muss ja irgendwo herkommen.
Und die kommt wahrscheinlich kneten.
Wieso mit mit wasser gefüllt der luftballon mit kleinen löcher der aber gedrückt wird sozusagen.
Genau ist ja ja genau meine zeiten kräfte wie es hier vom,
und dass das wasser in den flüssig sein kann bei diesen temperaturen die außen herrschen oder sagt auch einiges eben über die energie die von planeten zum zum mund,
übertragen werden und das ist physikalisch extrem spannend oder,
wie kann man so viele energie dass das wasser flüssig flüssig rauskommt erzeugen dort draußen.
Aber das rätsel was ich da jetzt automatisch im kopf kriege ist wie kann es denn bitte sein,
dass wenn jetzt unser sonnensystem sich mehr oder weniger aus demselben sternen gemisch sternen staub gemisch entstanden ist,
also der max der varianten drin geben aber das jetzt so extrem sind das jetzt ausgerechnet bei dem titan der sich im saturn dreht
alles auf einmal mit irgendwie metall am start ist und gefühlt ein paar meter weiter hat man ein komplett anderen mond körper,
ganz andere verteilung aufweist ist wie kann sich denn das so
heraus separieren ist da irgendwie die chemie schon von vornherein so gelagert dass ich in in diesem wolken,
war sie gleich und gleich gerne gesellt und dann sozusagen erstmal so einen kleinen himmelskörper für sich macht oder hat sich das dann auf dem saturn irgendwie zusammen geballt und es dann durch irgendetwas heraus geschossen worden
was kann man.
Meiner meinung nach spielverlauf,
bildung eine rolle und wahrscheinlich ist servus und die dann nicht am selben ort entstanden.
Möglicherweise sind beide eingefangen worden vom.
Es kann auch sein dass einer mit dem satt und zusammen entstanden ist ich weiß die neueste forschung nicht,
verfolgt aber die sind ziemlich sicher am gleichen ort entstanden und haben auch nicht die gleiche größe und größe spielt auch keine rolle der marsch auch relativ nahe beieinander,
und trotzdem völlig verschiedene noch einmal ganz anders,
also die distanz sonne die distanz zu ihrem grossen,
planeten bei den mond die spielt eine ganz große runde,
und das sonnensystem der personal nebel war relativ homogen am anfang.
Aber innen was mehrere tausend grad warm oder außen was dreißig kelvin oder zehn kelvin,
da geht die post an meiner bleibt als eis das ist was mir bei kometen sehen,
während im inneren des sonnensystems die moleküle die vom vorher kommen alle in die einzelteile zerlegt wurden bevor sie wieder zusammen.
Also das ist einfach die distanz zum stern die das wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich.
Das heißt es ist im wesentlichen tatsächlich erstmal die temperatur die bei der.
Temperaturen dichter dichter dichter die bestimmen die sonne ist es extrem heister werden keine komplexen moleküle überleben oder die.
Die einzelteile zerlegt auch das wasser wird wahrscheinlich mehrheitlich in bevor er sich dann wieder vor allem.
Das heißt wenn dinge unendlich sind dann weiß es eher darauf hin dass sie mal woanders waren.
Genau ganz genau.
Wirklich so viele unterschiedliche monde um saturn herum kreisen zeigt es mir von der masse der saturn der in der lage ist sich irgendwas einzufangen was vielleicht noch nicht mal aus denselben staub scheibe heraus entstanden ist danach sein.
Könnte prinzipiell sein aber die relativ geschwindigkeiten sind dann meistens so groß dass die bei fliegen die kann man nicht so einfach einfahren.
Okay das muss dann schon größere.
Aber wir wissen dass planeten migriert sind oder gewandert sind im frieden sonnensystem die haben verschiedene,
von der sonne weg durchlaufen und je nachdem wo sie den mund geklaut haben oder,
also es gibt jetzt dann eine japanische mission mix zu verpassen von mais und dort will man rausfinden oder wurden die akquiriert also bis später,
irgendwoher angefangen oder wurden die mit uns zusammen gebildet das ist so die erste stufe die,
man muss rausfinden sind die man dort gewesen hätte oder mehr.
Und da ist dann wiederum die cosmo chemie auch der schlüssel weil in dem moment wo man sich das genau anschaut dann.
Richtig zahlt dann weiss man unter welchen bedingungen diese mond entstanden sein muss und ob das kompatibel mit.
Was sind denn jetzt so die aktuellen neuen,
fragen die sich jetzt in diesem noch relativ jung feld herausgestellt haben,
also wenn es vor zwanzig jahren noch so ein bisschen verkannt das gebiet war müssen wir nun mittlerweile so an dem punkt,
angekommen sein wo es im prinzip so einen so einen großen katalog gibt auch mal jenseits jetzt dieser rein,
lebens frage worauf liegt der fokus und worauf,
auch der fokus neuer mission die jetzt in diesem bereich hilfreich sein soll.
Ich glaube für die boden gestützte astronomie die haben noch nie.
Die es ist einfach ein neues medium zu analysieren als die protokolle da entscheiden wegen vielen stark dann sieht man es nicht mehr richtig.
Also mit brutto planetarium scheiben meinen wir das was letzten endes einen planeten formt oder alle planen.
Alle planeten also bei der scheibe hat sich der stern schon zum teil gebildet.
Planeten sind am bilden oder die chemie verstehen wir noch nicht was was eben was jetzt dort wirklich abgeht oder was beim position von einem saturn abgeht position von,
dieser chemie müsste man studieren können und das kann man noch nicht nehme anders wird immer besser.
Weil man einfach nicht so viele beobachtungen hat aus dem man.
Ja mein mann hat so nein aber schwierig zu beobachten weil sie sehr viel staub haben und das macht ihr ein signal nicht gerade freude oder dann gehen die einzelnen linien der verschiedenen moleküle gehen,
in diesem sogenannten background.
Das heißt in dem moment wo sich ein sonnensystem bildet,
davon reden wir ja jetzt ja beim also sagen so eine größere gruppe und wir waren ja vorhin schon bei der entstehung der sonne und diese sonne gibt es und diese sonne ist dann zwangsläufig von dieser,
staub scheibe umgeben aus der sich dann planeten herausbilden und das haben wir ja schon gesehen,
es gibt halt natürlich erstmal die ganzen physikalischen unterschiede temperatur dich,
und natürlich alles was damit zusammenhängt also die anziehungskraft gravitation der einzelnen teilchen das aneinander reiben und das verklumpen also alles was physikalisch ab,
aber das ganze hat dann quasi auch noch eine
chemische begleiten musik die natürlich durch diese ganzen parameter beeinflusst wird vor allem die temperatur und die dann eben unter umständen auch eine rolle spielen kann oder auf jeden fall spielt
was letzten endes hier ausgelost wird welche welche planeten sichern was sind denn das für chemische,
vorgänge die an der stelle auch so auf so 'ner skala überhaupt eine rolle spielen kann ist das dann irgendwie so so ein bisschen,
die komische kleid creme die dann sozusagen dazu führt dass irgendwas zueinander kommt.
Es kommt drauf an wo sie sich befinden in dieser scheibe,
die sogenannte mit plänen also die mittlere ebene ist dunkel haben sie fast kein zufall,
und damit wir nicht sehr wahrscheinlich aber wenn sie dann weiter drinnen sind haben sie vier temperatur das wird dann schon besser dann kann ich sie wieder machen,
und dann haben sie alle die dynamik dieser scheibe ist ja nicht stationär die bewegt sich und es geht material nach innen und nachher rausgeworfen vom stern,
und all diese vorgänge verstehen wir noch relativ schlecht also wie sich das sonnensystem dann wirklich bildet,
und was abgeht und eben welche art planet sich weiterbilden kann,
man hat immer gesagt das sonnensystem das musste so kommen oder ihnen die drei kleinen planeten,
und dann muss er sein.
Dann hat man woanders hingeschaut festgestellt ist.
Dann war war gerade neben dem stern war ein riesen planet.
Planet das war ein riesen planen,
direkt neben seinem stern miteinander zwei oder drei oder vier tage.
Und ein gas planet.
Planet gar nicht sein laut allen modellen,
heute hat man sehr viele gefunden dass die großen planeten innen sind und nicht um das zu verstehen dass kann man unter anderem mit der chemie tun.
Indem spezifisch ist für den nordwest.
Ja ich wollte mich gerade fragen okay,
woran kann man jetzt dieses modell verbessern das bedeutet die planeten forschung,
weil auch schon mal besprochen haben ist da eigentlich auch ein einer der schlüssel,
indem man sich möglichst viele andere sonnensystem immer besser anschaut also erstmal,
planeten entdeckt aber gibt es verschiedenste methoden die funktionieren relativ gut jetzt gerade leider käppeler außer betrieb gegangen aber andere,
andere teleskop mission sind in planung also das wird auf jeden fall wieder 'ne beschleunigung bekommen und man hat ja auch gesehen nachdem man die ersten methoden,
entwickelt hatte es ging ein ziemlich ab also man hat ja,
so eine extrem starken anstieg an entdeckung gehabt und ich weiß gar nicht wie viele sonnensystems mittlerweile,
gefunden wurden aber es geht.
Mehr als viertausend planeten ja ja.
In die tausende geht es so oder durchaus absehbar dass wir dann halt mit weiteren teleskopen noch verfeinert den techniken diese zahlen noch weiter nach oben bringen so dann wird das eine aufnahme eine interessante statistische masse auch an der man im prinzip diese chemischen modelle auch wiederum,
dran kalibrieren kann oder müsste man.
Uns ganz klar sein chemie bei diesen nächsten planeten es dann nochmal eine eine.
Aber was kann man denn messen jetzt durch die exoten planeten,
suche also welche informationen erhält man denn die man überhaupt chemisch anwende.
Man man versucht man versucht die atmosphäre zu messen und jetzt gerade wieder war eine meldung dass man wasserdampf gefunden hat in einer atmosphäre,
aber das ist schwierig weil die planeten sind in gottes namen klein,
mit der distanz sie leuchten nicht es ist nicht ein stern oder sondern das ist etwas das nicht leuchtet aber meistens von etwas ist das sehr gut leuchtet,
das ist so wie wenn sie neben kurz neben berlin eine kerze sehen müssen oder von weitem das sehen sie nicht nach berlin hell und dunkel.
Und von daher gesehen ist also man kann es jetzt nur mit,
indem man das licht der sterns hinten dran ist,
beobachtet wenn die atmosphäre des planeten schon ein bisschen vor dem sterben ist,
und anhand der linien die dann fehlen oder die man zusätzlich kann man etwas über dich sagen aber das ist noch extrem wenig.
Ja also im prinzip dieselbe methode es jetzt hier gerade letzten folge die erkenntnis lage über pluto ist ja beim vorbei flug auch die atmosphäre genauso gemessen worden das kann man halt sehr eingeschränkt,
machen das heißt darüber kann man erkenntnisse gewinnen die aber jetzt nicht ausreichend und dann wirklich alle fragen zu beantworten.
Genau genau und dafür braucht man einfach um ein mehrfach das machen zu können.
Ja jetzt wollt ich mal fragen was wäre denn sozusagen auf der wunschliste ja also wenn ich so wissenschaftler selber was äh so eine mission,
wünschen dürften was was müsste die machen.
Also für mich ist es ein kometen fan oder ich würde gerne noch einmal zu einem kometen gehen mit einem richtigen aufeinander,
der absetzt der richtig tief bäumen kann und dann die zusammensetzung im inneren des kometen,
ich glaube das wäre das wäre das richtige zu tun damit wir auch wieder unterscheiden kann was ist evolution und was ist vom anfang an da eben wie beim,
ich meine es sogenannte wetter,
im weltall erlebt sonnenwind kosmetische strahlung alles mögliche und dann müsste man dort auch tief gehen,
aber selbst bei kometen oder wir haben starke geschichten so es wäre gut,
richtig rein ein paar meter minimum hundert meter wäre noch besser,
und wird besteht das ist im moment noch nicht ganz absehbar aber ich hoffe dass das irgendwie.
Rosita die mission rosita eine wirklich außerordentlich,
erfolgreiche mission obwohl er genau dieser teil mit dem länder so ein bisschen,
schwierig war sag ich mal ja also es ist ja gelungen ihn landen zu lassen.
Gerade dieses rein bohren hat dann nicht richtig funktioniert die haben nicht ausgelöst,
dann hat man pech gehabt das ding ist irgendwie drei mal über die ganzen kometen rüber gehabt was interessante nebenbei erkenntnisse gebracht hat aber leider hat man sozusagen das eigentliche ziel allianzen lokal auf dem länder
stationiert instrumente alle zum einsatz zu bringen nicht vollständig erreicht,
könnte man natürlich sagen so ach ja nochmal zum kometen und so hat man ja schon aber ja gesehen dass eigentlich jetzt in dieser folge otto rosita dass all das wissen der vorherigen mission,
extrem gut zum einsatz gebracht werden konnte und man sieht ja auch bei den problemen die nation heute haben um die zum mond zu fliegen das diese lange lange pause nach dem
apollo mission jetzt so gut auch nicht wahr weil irgendwo braucht man einfach die erfahrung und so auch ein bisschen das,
spür der leute die sich schon vorher damit beschäftigt haben um sowas dann irgendwie auch erfolgreich zum einsatz zu bringen gibst gibt's denn sozusagen ein,
was haben sie das gefühl dass es sozusagen eine ein zuspruch dafür geben könnte wenn man sagt ok wir machen jetzt aber nochmal komet weil komet können wir und diesmal stürzen wir uns sozusagen auf die nächsten und beantworteten fragen.
Also die esa hat dieses jahr eine comedy mission ausgewählt kommentieren.
Die ausgewählte wird im zwanzig achtundzwanzig starten zusammen mit daniel das ist eine extra planeten mission.
Es ist eine sogenannte mission fast heißt auch billig.
Ja
Muss billig sein ist ein bisschen ein ein atom,
aber es ist eine lustige mission das wird ein ein space kraft sein das geht zuerst mal in den,
orange punkt zwei dreht sondern gleich groß ist,
und wir dort warten bis ein komet kommt von außen also vom direkt von rodewald zum ersten mal,
einen sogenannten neuen kommen noch besser wenn von ganz außen konto wir hatten jetzt den,
auch immer studierende,
der kam ja von außen und das schöne wäre wenn so einer dann gerade kommt oder wenn wir dort sind und warten.
Aber kann ja auch sein dass man erwartet was kommt nichts oder ist da so viel los das äh sehr.
Es ist wahrscheinlich genug los dass einer kommt man kann nicht nur zwei drei jahre war,
wenn man ihn dann kommen sie dann nichts wie los,
das wird ein vorbeifahren geben wie bei,
ein schneller vorbei flug dann wird's aber wir werden einen vergleich haben zum zürich eines neuen kometen oder eines extra solarium kometen mit,
mit zürich.
Das wird kommen hoffe dass dann später auch wieder eine große mission kommt eben mit einem land,
der landet und nicht einfach runtergeworfen wird hoffnung sondern steht,
und da kann man ganz ganz viele fragen beantworten.
Wie viel besser ist denn das instrumentarium geworden im vergleich zu dort wo ich meine das jetzt äh fast vierzig jahre her.
Also ich kann von unserem rosinen instrument massen spektrum meter mit einer auflösung von einem ganzen masse.
Mit rosinen konnten wir einen neuen tausendsten auflösen auf der neuen tausendmal besser.
War auch viel empfindlicher das instrument,
und dann haben wir alle dass viele organische zeugs messen können oder und identifizieren können groß seitdem das war ja gebaut in den sechsundneunzig bis zweitausend,
seitdem ist nicht mehr sehr viel passiert in massen sprechen.
Aber es ist auch nicht das einzige instrument was eine rolle spielt oder doch.
Nein aber das war war schon eines der schlüssel zum ende kameras die war sehr gut,
das ist auch gut bei den maß mission bei den neuen maß missionen die wird immer besser dort spielt natürlich die,
die computer hardware software eine große rolle für die kamera.
Drängt pass ist.
Dass die kamera auf jede menge daten erzeugen.
Aber mehr als man.
Viel mehr als man runter bekommt und die algorithmen um diese daten haben zum kopf premieren und sondern auszuscheiden das will ich das will ich nicht hängt natürlich mit guten rechenleistung zusammen.
Und natürlich auch mit neuen algorithmen prinzip stehen wir so ein bisschen so an dem punkt wo man sagen muss wir müssen eigentlich bestimmte entscheidungen auf der,
auf dem auf der sonne selbst fällen was man wegschmeißt und was man nicht wegschmeißt das natürlich knifflig ne.
Ja das geht zusammen mit der maschine learning mit big data.
Wenn man die rechten power hat auf dem spacex kraft dann kann man sehr viel machen und ich nehme an dort wird die entwicklung mehr vorwärts gehen als auf der eigentlichen sensor sein.
Das problem mein maschine learning ist ja immer dass man eigentlich die maschinen das beibringt was man schon weiß und das ist eigentlich die eigentliche erkenntnisse aus den sachen kommen die man noch nicht wahr.
Das ist gefährlich das ist vielleicht ein bisschen gefährlich aber ich muss sagen wir haben für china,
aber zwei personen von,
von berlin mathematiker haben sich dein problem angenommen und haben jetzt dank big data haben die sachen rausgeholt die wir nie rausgeholt hätten schließen da.
Aber aus daten die gesendet wurden.
Die gesendet worden aber das kann man im prinzip schon oben machen.
Ja gut aber da kann man ja dann auch immer wieder immer wieder alle daten nehmen und gucken.
Nein aber wenn sie's nicht runterkriegen die daten.
Dann ist es die frage ob uns überhaupt sozusagen erhält oder nicht ja.
Das ist das problem bei rosen hätten wir um möglich mehr daten runterkriegen können wir haben die voll ausgenutzt die daten.
Das sind halt einfach die ganze zeit.
Aber wenn wir jetzt ein instrument oder eine kamera mit besseren auflösung gehabt hätten.
Wer gar kein platz mehr gewesen für die andere instrumente.
Make-up pixel oder so etwas kamera.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so viel.
Heute haben wir das handy oder,
das kriegen sie nicht mehr runter also müssen sie intelligent also ob man schon vorarbeiten.
Ja und vor allem dann so eine suche wie wo ist denn viele so.
Genau richtig ja ja ja ja ja ja.
Das interessant gewesen wenn man das so algorithmus hätte lösen können.
Also ich bin fast sicher am meisten wird in dieser beziehung gehen oder dass man sehr viel mehr umbaut macht und weniger von handel langsam.
Das ist richtig forschungs- philosophische frage an der stelle sehe ich schon wieder so 'ne szene von zweitausendeins von meinem geistigen auge wo dann so der board computer selber darüber entscheidet was er den menschen mitzuteilen bereit ist das nicht.
Es abgefahren oder man muss immer eingreifen können.
Ja frau alt weg noch ein aspekt den wir noch kurz ansprechen sollten so zum abschluss ist tangieren was man mal so wissen bis.
Nein haben wir viel viel erzählt.
Das auf jeden fall ja gut dann sag ich vielen dank.
Sie wollen mich noch fragen wie meine positionierung mein leben verändert hat.
Das.
Ich kann schon sagen seitdem funktioniert bin.
Man kommt auch von dem thema nicht weg oder.
Ja oder ich habe keine administration mehr ich mache keine leere mehr und jetzt kann ich effektiv forschung machen und das mache ich auch.
Hält sie keiner zurück super,
auch nicht mehr vielen dank für das gespräch und ja vielen dank fürs zuhören die über raum zeit das war's für heute und guten monat geht's dann wieder eine andere wunderbare welt der raumfahrt in.
Bis dahin.